we always say that
the relationship between israeli
companies and japanese corporations is
really creating a synergy
together we can create
great value so we always say israelis
are making zero to one and japanese are
good in making one to one hundred
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm honored to have noah
asher with me the ceo of ntt innovation
laboratory israel
ntt israel serves as the focal point for
entity group companies in israel and
their mission is to bring value to ntt
by collaborating with israeli companies
in academia in various fields ntt is one
of the major players in the japanese
communication market and is considered a
fortune 100 company with over 100
billion dollars of annual sales more
than 300 000 employees worldwide
operating in 80 plus countries
from 2014 to 2020 noah served as the
economic minister at the israeli embassy
in tokyo where she was in charge of
promoting trade and investments between
israel and japan supporting the
revolution that happened during this
time in the business relations between
israel and japan
noah joined the ministry of economy in
2002 and held several positions at the
foreign trade administration and the
innovation authority including the
commercial attache in chicago
previously she was the legal advisor in
a group of startup companies
no asha welcome to 20 minute leaders
from ranana usually before tokyo but now
welcome how are you great
i'm good how are you i'm doing great
thank you so much for joining me i'm
excited to learn you know all about
tokyo japan israel relations trade
economics and you know and the entity
group that you're part of and what
you're doing there
previously with the embassy in in tokyo
but now
a part of mtt so really really
interesting things tell me a little bit
about yourself and and how you found
yourself
dealing with the economics and trade
between israel and japan
wow
long story
um i actually
um i actually started my career at the
end of the 90s as a legal advisor
in a group of israeli startup companies
so that was when the whole bubble
started uh israel evcs were established
um and i worked mainly you know on a
day-to-day
legal issues and also investment rounds
in the in the startups
um
i didn't like being a lawyer at all
i left
maybe three years after
when i was accepted to the diplomatic
course at the israeli ministry of
economy and trade
i spent 18 years there so 2002 to
which were really really amazing
exciting time for me
very diverse
i could really you know i could really
feel that i'm making an impact a lot of
independency a lot of responsibilities
in different in different positions that
i held
i started there at the asia pacific
department when we just started
all the relations with that china we
actually had a very large delegation in
2004 to china we had 200 israeli
businessmen going there
and the whole kind of hype about israel
and asia started of course china at the
beginning
but i'm very happy to see the tilt
moving into japan as well
after working at the asia pacific
department i moved actually to the chief
scientist office
today the innovation authority
i spent very few years as the chief of
staff
working with the chief scientist on some
reforms or new programs new projects
that will help and support the israeli
industry
and then i moved to chicago i spent five
years in the u.s
as the commercial at the share at the
consulate in chicago
a very exciting time working on
promoting relationship between israel
and the midwest
14 states in the midwest
mostly i was focused on
medical life science i worked with all
the big names at the in the area baxter
abbott medtronic
to bring them to collaborate with
israeli companies in that field
i also had the opportunity to spend one
year at the harvard kennedy school as a
wexner fellow
where i did my master's in public
administration which was really great
great time
you know
mostly for me meeting
so many different people from you know
from different countries that are in
high positions that are we could really
study and learn from from each other
this was this was great i came back and
i worked at the ministry of economy um
heading the financial uh department um
promoting new programs that will help
israeli exporters working
international markets
and then i was
very fortunate
to was that to to
be appointed as the economic minister at
the embassy of israel in japan
i spent six years there
six years that could really you know be
defined as the revolution time
in terms of the economic relations
between israel and japan
where japanese companies japanese
government
started seeing israel as a legitimate
place to do business with and also
this was actually part of the 2014 caden
ren visit to israel they said it it's
not just
okay to do business with israel but it's
also beneficial to both sides so that
was when the japanese industry started
understanding the value that the israeli
industry could bring to them and help
them stay as global leaders
global innovation leaders or try to be
global innovation leaders and stay in
the competition
so six years in japan very very exciting
i came back in august 2020 and i was
very
happy to receive a proposal from ntt
um ntt
realized as well that they have a great
value um to earn from having a center
here in israel and we established the
center on july 1st so
two months ago we are very new
um and
we are serving as the focal point uh for
entity group companies there are 989
companies in ntt
um to the israeli innovation so we are
here
to help entity group companies
work with israeli companies identify
opportunities for investment for
collaboration for joint r d
for new businesses distribution of
israeli products and technologies
and we are working
mostly now as matchmakers um identifying
the needs and the opportunities in
israel and trying to establish new
platforms that will promote this
collaboration incredible incredible so
so take me back a little bit tell me
tell me about the the tokyo landscape
you know that where we spent some time
and both you know in relation to to
israel but also you know what's
happening there in terms of innovation
technology and how how is israel playing
some role within that
so
you know japanese economy is one of the
largest economies in the world it's now
number three used to be number two um it
it um had
the two lost decades maybe now a little
bit more
i'm trying to figure out you know after
all the big companies such as you know
the car manufacturers panasonic sony
and others started losing their um
their status their global status they
were trying to find out ways where they
could really stay in that competition
and achieve
new value
israel was not on the map of the
japanese industry until 2014
there was very limited collaboration
between israeli and japanese
corporations in terms of investments in
terms of joint ventures there is almost
no knowledge actually about israel
in japan
and that's where yeah that's where
everything started to to shift um
in japan
government to government relationships
are very influential so they influence
the industry top down
and in 2014 there was a visit of the
caden ren to israel as i said before
which are the the big
organization of of all the all the big
companies in japan
and that's where they said that it's
legitimate and beneficial to do business
with israel then we had uh netanyahu our
prime previous prime minister visit
israel and visit japan in 2014
and that's where everything started to
roll so it was like you know like a rock
was moved out of uh out of a dam
and the river started streaming
um what was it about what was it about
the visit that that opened the canal and
opened the stream too loud for this
so this this was this was the
netanyahu's visit after that um you know
he had very close uh relations with uh
then prime minister abe
they decided on collaboration in various
fields cyber security and others and r d
a few months after he invited actually
the minister of economy in japan to come
to visit israel and july 2014 was when
the first uh
first time that the japanese minister of
economy came to visit israel and signed
an mou for joint r d
and this is something that we worked on
for many many years and it was finally
done
then
and then prime minister abba visited
israel january 2015 and every time there
was such a meeting such a summit you
know new agreements were signed new
declarations um in in january 2015
actually the israeli government received
a resolution to promote the
relationships between israel and japan
seeing japan as a strategic partner
economically
politically
and we were fortunately allocated with
great uh great uh you know budget and we
could do many many different programs
um to uh
encourage those relationships so one of
the things that we did was actually
campaigning for israel
we were campaigning um you know so we
will be able to create awareness in the
japanese industry
working on showcasing israel as a
startup nation as an innovation hub
which is very very relevant
for the japanese companies we always say
that
the relationship between israeli
companies and japanese corporations is
really creating a synergy
uh together we can create
um great value so we always say israelis
are making zero to one and japanese are
good in making one to one hundred um i
actually had a visit of the former ceo
of uh sony in israel mystery day and
when he came back he told me you know
you're saying it's wrong you should say
israel is good and making minus
one to one so coming up with a new
disruptive idea and bringing it uh to
the table and then the japanese
corporations could start uh
uh working on that collaborating on that
so we really see that this synergy being
created
between japanese and israeli companies
and it was like a you know almost
taboola rasa so almost nothing was done
before almost no connections were there
and from 2014 to 2020 now even even even
more and even though we are facing covet
we still see the great growth in
relationship
uh there were
there was as i said a revolution in
terms of of uh economic relations the
investment went from almost nothing to
more than eight billion dollars in
israel japan became a very important
investor into the israeli industry in
2020 if i remember correctly 20
japan became 12 percent um of the fdi
towards israel invested 12 percent uh in
israel so they became a very important
player in the israeli economy there are
acquisitions of israeli companies by the
japanese corporations many joint
ventures
between them a lot of great uh great uh
projects and collaboration and also as a
government we were able to create all
sorts of platforms that could promote
and encourage this relationship
we one of the platforms that we started
is called jin this is a japan israel
innovation network and it's actually a
network of all the important economic
organizations both in japan and in
israel
in japan there is a
those organizations are really
leading the industry so kedan ren as i
said quesadilla ukai which is an
organization of the top executives of
the big companies in japan all of them
were part of our group
working together to promote a
relationship one of the greatest
milestones was in january 2019 when the
then minister of economy from japan came
to israel with 200 businessmen from
japan
top executives from 99 japanese
companies they came to israel and we
organized a festival
a japan israel festival
created hundreds of meetings between
those corporations and the israeli uh
startups and companies
and this you know everything that you do
is really influencing the industry the
japanese in the japanese companies like
to follow so
they usually are not the first to
initiate um you know a new trend but
then when they see the
so many executives government
everybody is working with israel
you know every every day that i was in
japan i met a new company that i wasn't
even familiar with you know companies
that we tend uh we tended to see under
the radar so i don't know companies of a
value of 1 billion or 900 million but
those companies are very relevant to do
business with israeli companies they're
interested in in new businesses they are
interested in acquiring new israeli
companies so it kind of influenced the
whole industry not just in the tokyo
area but also
in in you know more remote areas in
western japan in osaka kansai area
we saw great great
joint ventures uh and great
collaboration incredible what about the
culture differences right i mean the two
very strong cultures but how did that
come into play as you were witnessing
the beginning of trade and investments
so we you know when you have the map of
of uh the israeli and japanese culture
this is you know 180 degrees
it's so different and it's so opposite
um so there's a lot of of negotiations
that needs to be done here
and this is where i think i come in with
my you know six years experience of
working with a japanese companies and
managing a japanese team at the embassy
but there is a great difference but
that's where i i think really
the
the capabilities of the israeli of the
israelis and the features of the
japanese are really completing uh
completing each other and creating this
uh this synergy
israelis have to learn how to work with
japanese you know for japanese
harmony
is maybe a top value so there is no
there there's no uh win-lose situation
you're only creating a win-win situation
you're looking at your partner you want
the partner to benefit from the
transaction you want you want to have a
long-term
you know a long-term relationship that
is based on trust um it's very important
for them to create this harmony uh to be
full you know full
full board on on the collaboration
and it's hard for israelis they have to
change their mindset they're not here to
win
they're here to create this
harmony of working together and
understanding the needs of the other
side and there are many differences and
i can talk about it uh very very long
and there are a lot of things that
israelis have to learn
the the the biggest uh challenge for us
israelis is the speed you know speed of
making decisions is in in japan is very
very slow
sometimes it's too slow for the israeli
startups that are they need to to uh you
know understand what's going on very
very quickly and they always have others
other opportunities so this is a great
challenge that we have to overcome
we are trying to navigate and and bridge
those differences um in order uh to make
it more uh valuable for for israelis and
for now for entity not to lose
great opportunities that they have here
in japan in israel
we can talk about this first for so much
longer and but i want to get to know you
a little bit better as well take me back
you know before you were
a legal advisor and in the ministry
you know what fascinated you as a kid
what really sparked your curiosity
so i i think from a very young age i
love traveling i spent uh two years in
junior high in edmonton alberta canada
you know somewhere
up there
um
and every every minute that we spend
there you know my when we arrived my
father bought this trailer and we
traveled everywhere we uh drove to
alaska we drove to that you know us
everywhere
um and
and i just loved it i could never
handle routine life
this was very hard for me as a lawyer i
think
um and and i loved i loved traveling i i
i spent those years in canada after that
i kept on traveling i worked
at the uh at the military as uh
intelligence officer in the foreign
relations at the uh
at the intelligence forces um i always
liked this exposure to foreigners i
always liked learning about new cultures
i always liked that traveling i worked
as a when i went to law school i worked
as a flight attendant in el
i just
enjoy enjoy those like this this type of
life and
and i think that my career in the in the
ministry really
feel that that need
and what inspires you right now in the
day-to-day
so you know the transition from the
public
sector to the private sector was very
dramatic for me i i loved the feeling of
making an impact you know working at the
ministry i really felt
that i could do good for the israeli
economy for the israeli industry i was
very attentive
to the needs
of the israeli industry and i felt that
i could really make those changes
different programs support them in many
ways
to make to make this impact
now at ntt you know i'm not working for
the israeli government but i am working
for the israeli industry ntt
it's the whole world it's a country
there are 989 companies under this group
working in more than 88
countries and regions it's a huge
conglomerate working in many different
fields
we are here focusing on cyber security
digital health care and ai but you know
every day i discover a new company under
entity entity agrotechnology
you know working on agrotechnology
products and also entities satellites
everything so every day i discover a new
company uh we receive requests from
cyber security as i said to energy
to agrotechnology to fashion tech so i
feel like i'm very you know i'm here to
help the israeli industry
and create value for entity so i'm here
i really want uh this feeling of making
an impact a great contribution to um to
israel
and if there are a few words that would
describe you what would they be
um i thought about it i'm a mother i
think this is my first thing
i have three great kids
i'm a matchmaker
i've been
doing this since i was 10 you know in
fourth grade i was the matchmaker of the
girls and the boys i was bridging them
and i think i took this
ability to my career so i think i'm a
matchmaker still
um
a wife
uh hopefully my my husband can describe
me like that but you know
balancing this work life
and uh
yeah so mother matchmaker and wife i
think
i love it i love it thank you very very
much no this was wonderful
and best of luck with ntt and what are
you doing here with israel and thank you
for your time stay safe and stay healthy
you too thank you it's great talking to
you bye